alors monsieur les snobs comment se
porte votre doigt l'autre piqûres
d'insectes ne vous fait pas trop
souffrir regardez vous même mon cher ami
quelle dextérité à retrouver mon doigt
sinistrés
il n'y paraît presque plus n'est-ce pas
ah ouais c'est à dire que pour ma
nouvelle oeuvre d'art que je vais
bientôt sculpter des fleurs de nénuphars
l'otan sur un océan démonter et bien je
n'ai pas trop de mes dix doigts vous
savez malheureusement je rêve chaque
nuit en cours de ce monstre hideux se
précipitant sur moi par surprise âge et
dans le nouveau livre que j'ai une
recevoir il y à une fable que j'aimerais
beaucoup vous lire
vous connaissez mon goût pour la poésie
mon cher ami
d'abord appelons les enfants ça les
intéressera certainement les enfants
venaient frénésie de venez vite
je vais vous lire une fable de la
fontaine installée vous
je vous livre une fable de la fontaine
qui s'appelle le chameau ailé bateau
flotte corps écoutez bien bonjour
françois bonjour monsieur du snav
bonjour les enfants
vous n'aurez pas voulu lire car elle
m'avait donné rendez vous ici à l'envers
travail à me confier non casimir nous
n'avons pas vu julie mais puisque elle
t'a donné rendez-vous ici attends là
elle ne va sûrement pas tarder et héros
en attendant joins toi nous je vais lire
aux enfants et à monsieur du snad une
fable de la fontaine le chameau et les
bâtons flottant à noter qu'au talent
écoute à venir
le premier qui vite un chat moore
sont fuite à cet objet nouveau le second
approcha le troisième aux affaires un
lit coup pour le dromadaire
l'accoutumance ainsi nous rend tous
familiers ce qui nous paraissait
terrible et singulier s'apprivoise avec
notre vue quand je viens à la continue
et puisque nous voici tombé sur ce sujet
on avait mis des gens aux gays qui
voyant sur les eaux de loin certains
objets ne purent s'empêcher de dire que
c'est est un énorme navire
quelques moments après
l'objet de vin brûlot et puis nacelle et
puis bal ou enfin bâton flottante au
monde
j'en sais beaucoup de par le monde à qui
ceci conviendrait bien de loin c'est
quelque chose de près
ce n'est rien
c'est une très jolie fable et qui va
très bien à certaines personnes haraoui
tu veux certainement parler casimir de
emile campagne notre facteur mais pas du
tout monsieur du snob pas du tout cette
fable fait allusion à l'insecte énorme
qui vous a piqué le doigt
à julie te voilà enfin se désole que je
viens du port et mes colis ne sont pas
arrivés tu sais que j'avais commandé
trois kilos de dragées au poivre et
trois paquets de caramels mous et bien
le capitaine m'a dit qu'il ne serait pas
là avant 5 heures bon ça ne fait rien je
vais aller faire ma sieste et plusieurs
reviendrai et nous irons ensemble c'est
elle rapporte que les plus loin si
gentil casimir mais à cette heure là il
ya beaucoup d'enfants dans le jardin et
je ne peux pas m'absenter bon leur
écoute ça ne fait rien j'irai tout seul
puisque quelques paquets de plus ne me
font pas peur
seulement ensuite
ensuite
ensuite tu me donneras quelques dragées
au poivre
peut-être et quelques bonbons miellat
enverra est un peu de caramel mou c'est
possible bon d'accord en attendant
pourrais tu me donner quelques dragées
normal hein juste question de faire un
peu de place dans tes beaucoup par
exemple
pour le voyage
casimir
kazemi
tranquille et casimir il est 4 heures
kwh années déjà je viens à peine de me
coucher mais tu as bien demander qui ont
réveillé à 4 heures oui c'est vrai on la
laisse joue c'est vrai je dois aller au
port chercher lé paquet julie un bon
soutien françois m'a raconté tout à
l'heure une histoire à monsieur du snob
il semblait ne pas apprécier du tour
compliqué ce que c'était que l'histoire
pourrait bien cela parlait de chameaux
et dromadaires
ces grosses bêtes qui ont plein de
bosses partout partout partout non alors
là certainement pas non des bêtes qui
ont des bosses partout ça n'existe pas
ce serait crowley non je t'assure
casimir j'ai un cousin qui en a déjà
rencontré côte alors là je ne te crois
pas d'ailleurs je vais vérifier
alors c'est julie ac toi françois bon
jour dis moi
j'aurais posé une question c'est cet
abruti dans l'ailé nord prétend comme un
abruti cette écoute toi tu laisses moi
téléphoner tranquille ah oui et il
prétend qu est ce que tu prétends déjà
je ne prétends rien j'affirme que les
chameaux et les dromadaires sont des
animaux qui ont des branches partout
partout tu as entendu françois mary et
casimir j'ai entendu il a raison et tort
en même temps le chameau est un animal
qui a deux bosses
tu vois ce que je disais
le dromadaire lui n'a qu'une bosse
ararat tu as tu as entendu un une bosse
ce n'est pas des bosses partout
casimir tu sais que le dromadaire et le
chapeau sont des animaux qui vivent très
souvent dans le désert et il en arrive
parfois de rester plusieurs jours sans
manger sans boire et c'est la grèce qui
est dans leur dos qui leur sert de
réserve sont des animaux très serviable
et très sobre
merci du renseignement françois au
revoir
tu as entendu il a dit très serviable
acquis sans doute pour ça comme monsieur
du snob me prêtent souvent de chameau
d'ailleurs comme je suis serviable il
faut vite que je me dépêche d'aller
chercher les parts et de julie au corps
à plus tard ouais c'est ça une pense que
je pense je savais bien que jamais
raison donc le chameau plus un
dromadaire ça fait trois ans et ça fait
déjà plein de bosses plein de pensées
c'est déjà 3 po c'est déjà beaucoup pour
ça donc ils ont 15 ans et j'avais raison
des bons scores la nuit va bientôt
tomber
ce n'est toujours pas le retour tu as
presque du mahdi il avait beaucoup de
colis la portée alors avec la chaleur
accablante qui l'a fait cet après midi
il faut qu'on soit bien nous allons
aller à sa rencontre pour l'aider le
pauvre bonne idée julie
casimir mais que c'est du passé
rien il ya du tout pourquoi ou sur les
colis les tel colis allez les paquets on
laisser moi vous expliquer il faisait
chaud très chaud jomar 16 ans
marseillais les bombes ont commencé à
fondre à alors j'ai fait comme un
chameau keisha mode continu désigné
continuer bien le chameau très sombre un
i mange des kilos et fait des provisions
dans sa bosse pour le voyage alors j'ai
mangé tous les bonbons tu as mangé les
18 kilos de bongo oui
c'est bien dieu dit tu vas avoir très
mal au ventre quand ce ne sont pas les
bonbons qui me font mal au ventre ce
sont les papiers
kazimi